arguably the most influential of the
Mota berun at this time was IBN barajan
he was a great Mystic and Scholar from
the city of Seville known then in Arabic
as ishpilia the mysticism that he
practiced was one more strongly
connected to the motabirun and even
masada's ideas of contemplation
he moved to the countryside in order to
be closer to Nature where he could
practice by meditating on nature and
witnessing the Divine traces and the
truth that was manifested in it just
like IBL masara even barajan believed
that one could Ascend to the Divine
through this gradual contemplation of
God's science and traces his Revelation
a correspondence between the different
kinds of qurans the way that God reveals
himself through the three modes of
Revelation nature the written Quran and
the human self all these three are to be
studied and meditated upon to reach the
Divine just like how IBN masara
described the ascent on the ladder to
God